the president of ride-sharing company
lifts as the deadly crash in Arizona
involving an uber self-driving SUV could
have been prevented lyft is continuing
trials of its own autonomous vehicles
uber has now decided to stop testing its
driverless cars in California
uber tests are also suspended in Arizona
lifts market share is growing its 2017
revenue crossed the billion dollar
threshold the company says that's up a
hundred sixty eight percent since the
end of 2016
John Zimmer is co-founder and president
of lyft John good morning welcome thanks
for having me any pause about your
ownself driverless vehicles after the
the uber decision I think everyone
should take pause when there's a tragedy
like what happened in Arizona but it's
also important to zoom out and
understand why companies are doing this
and the fact is that 35,000 people every
year are killed in a car accident and
the ultimate goal is to bring that to
zero are you noticing that there's more
of an increase in in lyft mentions you
know before John it used to be uber uber
uber but now I see it's uber and lyft in
the same conversation I see more
cultural references to lifts in movies
and on TV shows so I'm wondering from
your point of view what's working for
lyft I for one I'm glad you got rid of
the pink mustaches but you did a long
time ago but what is working what's
working for you guys I think what's
working well is our vision which is to
improve people's lives with the world's
best transportation the way we treat
people whether that's our drivers or
passengers my background or our team
members or employees my backgrounds in
hospitality and so to me this was always
a service business what does that mean
hospitality like hotels hotels school oh
not technology okay right yeah and I one
of my first Jobs was a phone operator in
a hotel and and I saw the obvious
importance of taking care of people to
provide great service and I think that's
what's really paying off you actually
walked the walk - we should say listen
we always send a very nice car to pick
up our guests and we said we're gonna
send the car you said nope I'm gonna
take a lift I would like to do that I'll
get there on my own
but you also Drive you're also so
somebody can put in an order and you're
the one that picks them up while you do
that it's it's critical that we
understand
hire experience so every New Year's and
I try to every month as well I Drive on
on lifts and we learn a lot yeah I
learned a lot I learned the challenges
of being a driver on the platform the
opportunities for us to improve the
product for our drivers and I understand
better the passenger experience from a
different perspective
why is lyft better than uber lyft is
better than uber because we care about
improving our cities we care about
improving people's lives and we care
about the people that are behind the
business and nuber doesn't you
trillion-dollar market
ride-sharing why isn't eber or lyft
profitable yet the focus right now is on
on growth that the opportunity here is
that americans spend two trillion
dollars every year on car ownership know
we spend more money on cars than we do
on food but we use our car only four
percent of the time and so we're going
after that really large yeah you and
your co-founder Logan green you're
actually pushing for the end of personal
car ownership in major cities by by 2025
I believe it will make financial sense
for someone to own a vehicle in major
cities by 2025 because we spent the
house it won't mix it won't make
financial sense you spent $9,000 every
year owning and operating a vehicle when
you look at all the costs and you use
the car just four percent of the time on
average that does not make sense we can
give the equivalent of a five thousand
dollar tax credit back to every
household if we if we improve that
efficiency and that that's worth doing
oh that's a hard sell for me because
suppose you just want to run to the
store for just a second yeah I got to
wait and dial it in but I mean you're
raising an interesting point here you're
raising an interesting point the other
thing that I think is fascinating about
you and co-founder Logan Green is that
you guys are known as the good guys in
the business in the business world and I
think something that struck me
interesting is that you all just
recently ordered an internal audit last
year a self-imposed internal audit what
were you looking for why did you do that
we did an internal audit around equal
pay and and to me this is just obvious
if someone's obvious that if someone's
doing the same work they should be paid
the same and and we didn't want our team
members our employees to take our word
for it we wanted a third party to
validate that was true so we did that
last year
and I think it was yesterday we
announced our commitment to do that
every year
did you find discrepancies there was
about 0.6 percent discrepancies likely
from some type of unconscious bias or
just different opinions and we addressed
those John Zimmer thanks for being here
we appreciate it thanks for having me
yes good to see you